Hallo, Erbil ist mein Name. Ich bin auf diese Station als Assistenzartikel und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie Ihre Fragen jederzeit stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiß Kevin Jäger.
Können Sie Ihren Namen und Nachnamenbuch stabilen?
Ja, der Vorname Kevin, K-E-V-I-N.
Und Jäger, J-A, umlaut, G-E-R.
Okay, Herr Jäger, richtig?
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 20.
Ach so, ganz jung. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12.09.2004.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 180 und wie ich so 69 kg.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausass?
Das ist Dr. Schröder.
Was fühlt Sie zu uns?
Ja, eigentlich, wochen geht es mir schlecht.
Ich habe Fieber und ich bin total schlapp und habe immer Halsschmerzen.
Und ich habe Kopfschmerzen und im Bauch tut es mir wie.
Und ich kann nicht gut schlucken.
Erst habe ich eine Mandelentzündung oder so.
Aber nachdem das jetzt überhaupt nicht weggeht,
habe ich gedacht, ich muss jetzt doch mal in die Klinik kommen.
Und ja, jetzt, also das Fieber habe ich auch gedacht,
ja, das kommt und geht, wie so ein Infekt halt ist.
Aber nichts, das ist, also seit Wochen habe ich immer hohe Temperaturen.
Seit wie viele Wochen?
Ja, also erst habe ich gar nicht gemessen.
Aber vor zwei Wochen habe ich mal gemessen.
Und da hatte ich 39.
Das war jetzt nicht immer so hoch.
Das war nicht immer so hoch, aber immer über normaler Temperaturen.
Also seit zwei Wochen sind diese Beschwerden und diese Fieber?
Ja, die Beschwerden, das hat eigentlich schon vor drei Wochen angefangen.
Und ich habe natürlich gedacht, das geht wieder weg.
Was war es?
Ich halt Schmerzen gehen ja wieder weg, aber das ist nicht weggegangen.
Und ich bin inzwischen so schlapp und fühle mich so erschöpft,
auch weil ich nach dem natürlich nicht gut schlafen kann mit dem Fieber.
Und ja, okay.
Und diese Fieber ist so wählen für mich.
Ab und zu ist hoch und manchmal.
Ja, das ist nicht, das ist nie ganz.
Aber also so 39 war jetzt das höchste, was ich mal gemessen habe.
Okay, und Sie haben Schmerzen.
Ja, während des Flugens haben Sie auch so ein Problem.
Sie haben ja, genau.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch die Symptome von Grüppe,
wie laufende Nase, vielleicht Niesen sie oder?
Nee, sowas eigentlich nicht.
Ja, und bei so einer, bei so einer Grippe, bei so einer Schnupfnase
hat man ja auch keine Bauchschmerzen und nicht solche Kopfschmerzen.
Okay.
Und Ihre Kopfschmerzen, die sind auch seit zwei Wochen?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Ja, das ist mal mehr, mal weniger, aber eigentlich habe ich ständig
so einen dröhen Kopf.
Ja.
Und haben Sie vielleicht eine Schwellung bemerkt am Feins?
Ja, das ist mir tatsächlich auch gefallen.
Ja, dass das hier so ein bisschen geschwollen ist an der Seite.
Ja.
Und am Bauch, was für eine Schmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, so unter den Rippen eigentlich, so im oberen Teil.
Beide Seite oder nur rechts vielleicht?
Nee, ich würde sagen eher links.
Okay, einfach.
Haben Sie auch durch Ihren Mund den Hals geguckt
oder haben Sie sowas nicht gemacht?
Ich habe da mich reingeguckt, ob der Hals entzündet ist
oder so.
Ich habe dann auch mal so Lutsch-Tabletten genommen
oder so, aber das hat ja alles nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen dagegen?
Ja, ich habe natürlich mal Paracetamol genommen,
um das Fieber ein bisschen runterzufrücken.
Und wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Genau.
Ich habe so ein elektronisches Ding, wo man so an der Stirn misst.
Und wie ist Ihr appetiert?
Ja, zurzeit eher nicht so gut.
Haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Ich wüsste nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich abgenommen habe.
Meine Hosen passen mir noch alle.
Also, jedenfalls für mich.
Und wie ist es mit Ihrem Schlafen?
Ja, also wie gesagt, durch das Fieber schwitze ich manchmal jetzt nachts
und dann schlafe ich nicht gut, aber eigentlich fühle ich mich so durchgegen.
Ich möchte eigentlich den ganzen Tag schlafen.
Und wie ist es mit Ihrem Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen?
Hatten Sie Probleme damit?
Also das einzige Problem, was ich beim Stuhl habe,
ist, dass ich eigentlich immer so ein bisschen, dass ich ziemlich heftige Blähungen habe.
Das war immer so oder das ist nur?
Ja, das habe ich eigentlich schon lange, ja.
Haben Sie vielleicht so Unverträglichkeiten, so Naktoseintoleranz?
Also ich wüsste nicht.
Und beim Wasserlassen haben Sie keine Beschwerden?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen vor Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, also das ist so eine Unverträglichkeit, die aber sich nicht auf den Nahtausfall bezieht.
Ich muss mit Sonnenbestrahlung aufpassen.
Da kriege ich so einen Ausschlag im Gesicht.
Also insbesondere Gesicht und Hände sind betroffen,
weil ich natürlich auch am meisten Sonne abkriege.
Und insofern muss ich da immer so ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und wenn das ganz unangenehm ist, muss ich auch mal so Cortison-Salbe verwenden.
Und was ich jetzt habe, aber das ist eine ganz andere Baustelle.
Meine Achilles-Szene ist schon seit Wochen so chronisch entzündet.
Und deswegen kann ich zurzeit auch irgendwie gar keinen Sport machen.
Wie ist das aufgetreten, nach einem Unfall?
Ich denke vielleicht nach Überlastung.
Da haben wir mal eine größere Wanderung gemacht und danach hat es damit einmal so weh getan.
Seit wann ist das bei Ihnen?
Seit wann ist das?
Also das ist jetzt ungefähr schon fünf Wochen.
Eine andere Vorerkrankung ist bei Ihnen bekannt?
Ich wüsste nicht.
Vor einem Jahr hatte ich meine Lungenentzündung.
Und sind Sie dann stationär behandelt?
Nein, ich konnte wieder nach Hause und habe halt viele Medikamente bekommen.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Nein, also wie gesagt nur weil wir das Parazita-Molen und dann diese Cortison-Salbe im Sommer,
wenn ich ein bisschen zu viel Sonne abbekomme.
Sind Sie voll geimpft?
Ja, ich habe damals diese ganzen Corona-Impfungen, habe ich alle mitgemacht.
Und gegen auch diese Kinderkrankheiten auch?
Ja, das ist schon eine Weile her.
Also ich meine meine Eltern haben darauf geachtet, dass ich da alle Kinderimpfungen da bekommen habe.
Und noch eine wichtige Frage.
Gibt es auch jemanden bei Ihnen, die ähnliche Beschwerden haben?
Tatsächlich ja.
Also meine Freundin, mit der ich zusammenlebe, die sagt auch jetzt, dass sie so Halsschmerzen hat
und dass sie sich so viel bricht fühlt und so schlapp ist.
Und ja, wir hängen da jetzt irgendwie zusammen ein bisschen durch, ja.
Okay, ja, das kann auch eine Sache sein für uns.
Sie ist nach Ihnen oder vor Ihnen, war sie krank?
Das fing bei ihr später an.
Und sind Ihnen vielleicht auch Hautausschläge aufgefallen?
Bei mir? Nee, außer dieser Sonnengeschichte ist bei mir sonst kein Hautausschlag.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nee, tatsächlich noch nie.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, hin und wieder. Also ich bin kein starker Raucher.
Ja, so ein Päckchen. Ja, also, was weiß ich so in Gesellschaft, wenn man abends zusammen sitzt
und dann wird einer angeboten, dann rauche ich mal eine mit.
Aber eigentlich bin ich kein starker Raucher.
Ja, das ist gut. Trinken Sie vielleicht Alkohol?
Würde ich auch sagen gelegentlich. Also, ja, wenn es was zu feiern gibt
oder im Sommer jetzt mal ein Bier abends, wenn man, wenn man,
was weiß ich, abends zusammensitzt, aber eigentlich eher wenig.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine ganz routinemäßige Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen oder hatten Sie Kontakt?
Nee, mit Drogen habe ich, also da habe ich immer die Finger davon gelassen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Also eine Operation hatten Sie nicht gehabt.
Und wie ist das mit Ihrem Familie? Sie sind wahrscheinlich nicht verheiratet.
Ich bin nicht verheiratet, nee.
Leben Sie allein oder mit Ihrem Freund?
Ich wohne mit der Freundin zusammen.
Und also wie ist es mit Ihren Eltern?
Sind die Eltern gesund?
Mein Vater ist tatsächlich sehr früh gestorben.
Der hatte Schildrüßengrebs und der ist nur 47 Jahre alt geworden.
Wie alt? 47.
Schildrüßengrebs. Okay.
Und Ihrer Mutter?
Ja, da weiß ich nur, dass die,
die hat so ein Diabetes hat und dass die auch Probleme mit den Augen hat.
Also irgendwie an der Netzhaut ist etwas nicht in Ordnung.
Aber das wissen Sie nicht ganz genau.
Ganz genau, was da ist, weiß ich nicht.
Arbeiten Sie oder Sie sind stückländisch vielleicht?
Ich bin auch in der Ausbildung.
Ausbildung.
Worum geht es?
Als technischer Zeichner.
Es ist natürlich heute sehr viel Computerarbeit.
Technisch.
Technischer Zeichner.
Zeichen.
Okay.
Ja, ich möchte mal durchgucken, ob ich noch was Wichtiges fragen sollte.
Ja.
Und diese Schmessen während des, also Schluckens.
Ist das mit Flüssigkeit auch vorhanden oder nur mit Harte essen?
Also bei Flüssigkeiten merke ich das auch, aber bei festen Nahrung,
es ist natürlich unangenehmer, ja.
Okay.
Also so weit habe ich eigentlich alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich will natürlich wissen, was dahinter steckt,
weil ich irgendwann mal wieder fit sein will.
Das ist Sommer und man will rausgehen und ich fühle mich so schlecht
und habe das Gefühl, ich kann überhaupt nichts machen.
Genau.
Also die Kollegen haben gesagt auch, husten Sie auch?
Husten?
Nein, nicht, ich habe nicht husten.
Dann hätte ich irgendwie so eine Idee,
dass ich wieder eine Lunge habe, aber so fühlte ich mich nicht an.
Und sind Sie in letzter Zeit verreicht?
Ja, ich bin in letzter Zeit.
Nein, der Urlaub steht eigentlich noch vor uns.
Ich war nicht verreist.
Ja, also ich danke Ihnen.
Das war alles.
Ja, was kann man jetzt dagegen tun?
Wie geht es weiter?
Also ja, die Verbindung war schlecht, was haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, also ich habe gesagt,
ich habe gesagt, ich habe gesagt,
ja, also, was kann man gegen die Beschwerden tun?
Also, wir können noch vieles machen,
aber so erste möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und den Hals, genau also sehen selber
dann führen wir einige
Blutabnahmen und andere giftgebende Verfahren durch,
dann bespreche ich über sie auch sogar mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann können wir genauer wieder besprechen.
Also, gut.
Okay, danke.
Alum Knu und hat er gefragt.
Es kam eben als schriftliche Einblendung, hat er gefragt.
Und ich habe gesagt, ja, stimmt, tatsächlich, da am Hals ist es dick.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn sie im Abspricht anfangen wollen.
Okay, ja.
Kurzer Zeit.
Hat doch jemand sonst andere Fragen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe das nur gemerkt im Halsbereich, aber da habe ich jetzt auch nicht gesucht.
Okay, danke schön.
Die Beschwerden, früher ähnliche Beschwerden hatte ich nicht.
Abgenommen.
Ob ich abgenommen habe?
Ja.
Also, das hat er gefragt, ob ich ab oder zu genommen habe, habe ich nicht.
Und taucht jetzt noch eine Frage schriftlich auf, ob ich Gelenkschmerzen habe,
würde ich jetzt benähen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen.
Ja, sind Sie bereit?
Ja, genau.
Ich bin nicht so gut mit diesem Teil.
Aber das sind alle nicht so gut, machen Sie sich keinen Kopf.
Das Fragestellen ist immer einfacher als das Freiformulieren und das Berichten.
Da sind die sprachlich natürlich viel größer Hürden und Tücken.
Insofern gucken wir mal, aber nachdem sie sich doch jetzt bisher sehr gut geschlagen haben,
habe ich jetzt keine großen Bedenken.
Wir schauen.
Ja.
Hallo, Frau Oberarsten, ich hatte einen Patienten.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Es geht um Herrn Kevin Jaeger, 20-jährige Patient.
Er stellte sich, also geboren am 12.09.2004, ein Meter 80 groß
und 69 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns wegen seit drei Wochen bestehende Erschöpfung
und seit zwei Wochen begleitende Fieber.
Er hat auch, er hat, er hat Odinophage, was besonders mit fester Ernährung
sich verschlemmert, aber auch mit Flüssigkeiten ist auch vorhanden.
Das Fieber wurde am Stiel gemessen mit einem Elektrogerät
und die Frage nach laufenden Nase oder Grippesymptome wurde verneint.
Haben Sie nach dem Covid-Jest gefragt?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Die Frage nach einer Geschwollennach- heiss wurde bejaht.
Er hat auch Bauchschmerzen, besonders im linken Oberbau.
Gegen Schmerzen und Fieber hat er Parazitamol eingenommen,
ab und zu.
Und die vegetative Anamnese war bis auf Meteorismus
und vermehrtes Schlafen unauffällig.
Dieses vermehrtes Schlafen ist sehr wahrscheinlich wegen dieser Erschöpfung.
Anfallkrankungen ist bei ihm Achilles, Achilles-Szene,
er ist in Zündung bekannt seit fünf Wochen.
Er wurde einmal wegen einer Pneumonie ambulant behandelt.
Außerdem hat er eine Empfindlichkeit gegen Sonne
und dagegen nutzt er ab und zu Koalitionsalbe.
Er ist voll geimpft.
Was besonders wichtig ist, dass ihre Freundin auch
nach ihm ähnliche Beschwerden hat.
Ein wichtiger Hinweis?
Ja.
Eine Operation ist bei ihm nicht bekannt.
Er ist nicht raucher, nur gesellschaftlich, ab und zu.
Alkoholkonsum ist auch gelegentlich nur während Feiern.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er lebt mit seinen Freunden zusammen.
Die Eltern der Vater ist verstorben an einer Schildrüßung-Katzinum
mit 47.
Die Mutter leide an Diabetes-Militus
und hat Probleme mit Retina.
Aber was genau wusste er nicht?
Er macht eine Ausbildung als Techniker-Zeichen.
Die anamästischen Angaben deuten Armeissen
auf eine fichsös-mononiklos hin.
Als die franziellen Diagnose kamen,
eine Lymphomolkermähe und eine batterielle Entzündung.
Sehr gut.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Diagnostisch würde ich einen Halsabstrich durchführen.
Aussehren würde ich ein großes Blutbild,
CRP, Laborparameter,
und Leber- und Nierenwerte überprüfen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Halsabstrich.
Er hat auch Bauchschmerzen.
Was machen Sie zunächst?
Man muss den Hals durch den Mund gucken.
Man muss den Beleg auf den Tonzillen vorhanden.
Das ist ein wichtiger Hinweis für infektiöse Mononiploser.
Ich würde auch mit Handen abtasten,
ob eine Lymphknotenvergrößerung ist.
Was ist das für ein Halsabstrich?
Wir haben auch Verdacht auf andere Erkrankungen.
Deswegen müssen wir alle Punkte wie Axelhöhe und Leistenbereich.
Sehr gut.
Was sind besonders markante Werte, die uns Auskunft geben können?
Wir lassen ein großes Blutbild veranlassen.
Dadurch können wir eine Lymphozytose sehen.
Das bedeutet auf eine infektiöse Mononiploser hin.
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Man könnte infektiöse Mononiploser und IgM bestimmen.
Da gibt es einen Schnelltest.
Und Antikörpernachweise.
Wie wäre die Therapie für den jungen Mann?
Es ist wichtig, dass der Patient einen Bauchschmerzen hat.
Vielleicht hat er eine Splenomegale.
Wir müssen den Bauch und die innere Organe schonen.
Das heißt, keine sportliche Aktivität oder gefährliche Bewegung.
Wenn es um infektiöse Mononiploser handelt,
haben wir keine gezielte Therapien, sondern nur symptomatische.
Sehr gut.
Was ist die Krankheit, die in Deutschland noch hat?
Die hat noch einen anderen Namen.
Die Küssinkrankheit.
Sie heißt in Deutschland noch ein deutschen Namen.
Das habe ich gehört.
Pfeiffer.
Sie hat es mal rausgefunden.
Warum heißt es Mononukleose?
Wenn wir die Blutzellen unter den Mikroskop beobachten,
sehen wir, dass ich mich erinnere, große Zellen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, aber es geht darum.
Mit einem Kern.
Mononukleose.
Wunderbar.
Wir schauen uns den Patienten zusammen an.
Soll der wieder nach Hause gehen?
Das heißt, Paracetamol wirkt schon.
Dann können wir mit weiteren Medikamenten,
die überprüfen, das noch besser reduzieren.
Eigentlich könnte man den Patienten nach Hause schieben.
Mit der Maßgabe sich zu schonen.
Die Freundin muss man untersuchen.
Sie haben sich gut geschlagen.
Ich habe nichts zu bemängeln.
Ich konnte sie gut verstehen.
Ich fand sie schon im Fragenbereich.
Sie haben relativ häufig diese Standardformulierung.
Das kennen wir von allen.
Es ist nett, wenn sie sich für die kommenden Übungen
oder auch für die Prüfung überlegen.
Sie haben die Alternative aufgefallen.
Sie haben bemerkt,
das könnte man dann noch mal fragen.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
ob man verschiedene Formulierung machen kann.
Beim Arztgespräch
habe ich nicht nur den Klassiker gebracht.
Es stellte sich wegen.
Dann fehlte etwas.
Das ist die große Gefahr.
Aber sie haben nicht viel reingepackt.
Viele Kollegen machen das so.
Sie führen die ganze Litanei an Symptomen auf.
Es ist kein Wunder, dass man vergisst,
dass man nicht viel verwendet.
Es ist mir besonders aufgefallen, dass das fehlt.
Vorstellendes, trennbares Verb.
Die Prüfung kommt ans Ende, aber es muss auch kommen.
Wegen ist schon richtig.
Man muss nur genitiv machen.
Das ist nett.
Ich habe die Symptome.
Da fehlt nichts.
Was man vielleicht noch fällt mir gerade ein.
Wenn jemand Fieberhaltschmerzen angibt,
würde man wahrscheinlich sagen,
einmal Covid-Schnelltest machen.
Ich denke, ich leere nicht so ganz aus der Welt.
Was wollte ich noch sagen?
Mein Gott, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Es ist weg.
Irgendwas war mir noch schnell eingefallen.
Aber ich denke, sie haben eine schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Sie haben den Fall vollständig geschildert.
Sie haben eine stringente Untersuchung.
Das wollte ich.
Ultraschallemmel sollte man noch machen.
Du klickst Sonografie des Bauches.
Um da mal zu gucken, ob da irgendwas ist.
Möglicherweise mit einem Schallkopf,
die Lymphknoten einmal checken.
Das wäre das einzige, was mir zusätzlich noch einfiel.
Sie können sehr zufrieden sein.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir uns noch mal sehen.
Ob sie noch mal reinhorchen.
Ich sage das jetzt noch mal.
Ich bin ca. 2 Wochen bei meinen Kindern.
Ich kann jetzt noch nicht übersehen,
ob ich noch mal ein paar Termine sind.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es Tage, wo ich das machen kann.
Dass ich abends Konferenzen anbieten kann.
Ich würde mich bei Dr. Gündis melden,
sobald ich das übersehen kann.
Ich nehme das iPad mit.
Ich nehme ein paar Fälle mit.
Ich habe noch eine andere Uhr.
Je nachdem, wie die familiäre Situation am Ort sich darstellt.
Ich hoffe, alle bleiben gesund.
Für heute Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend.
Ein gutes Wochenende.
Es wird richtig heiß.
Ich melde mich, weil wir uns wiedersehen können.
Tschüss.